so first off
kind of Nepal ogia to the web and beyond
if you came here expecting explanation
for beyond it's probably not going to
happen I it's to the web beyond because
titles have to balance and sorry this is
just this is the shameless plug I've
been working on this book for a year so
I've been away from kind of Python and
JavaScript just put it in context but at
least the cutting edge so part of this
is my discovery of what's been going on
there in the last month or two ya titles
need to balance I couldn't just call it
to the web that would just just be wrong
wouldn't pars so I thought about to the
web with love I mean it's a bit kind of
hippie and James Bond defied for a PI
data talk that the sentiments there but
now I mean to the web and beyond has a
certain resonance and I I guess I feel
that I should try and give some
explanation for what the beyond might be
and I think there are some kind of
candidates we are entering a new realm
of virtual reality it's pretty
impressive i played with some of these
myself and i think the prospects for
data visualization and virtuality are
going to be very interesting so that's
pretty beyond if you leave Python for a
year and you come back and it's suddenly
3.5 and you were expecting 2.8 then
that's pretty weird it's got new
keywords like a sink no idea what that
is but and it's gotta wait it's suddenly
embracing a synchronicity and funnily
enough that's mirroring some of the
developments in JavaScript at the moment
which is trying to do the same thing
Python doesn't have the whole callback
soup horror to contend with in
JavaScript it's an important thing
beyond these what happens if you leave
JavaScript for a week
because there's a crazy pace of
development in the world of JavaScript
right now which I'll be addressing in a
minute it's got classes some of us don't
like that because we like prototypes and
we like telling people the prototypes
were better than classes but it gives
you a little bit of syntactic sugar
which is familiar and if you're a Python
esta that's going to help we have
inheritance my god we've got this fat
arrow symbolism symbols which makes
things look a little bit neater and yes
we've got a sink so JavaScript and
Python have have converged on this async
await pattern which uses promises and
will reduce some of the horrible
callbacks sufism which plagues
JavaScript and that's a good thing so
you've got modules and classes and
promises and they sink and generators
and blocks coping with let and lots of
other stuff basically javascript is
changing very very fast so if you if you
haven't been keeping abreast it's it's
getting a lot nicer to work with which
is very important if it's going to be
producing the data viz of the future I
was trying to distill what I kind of
felt about working with China saying
some people in this room who work with
JavaScript and I'm Python and what's the
kind of our other big ideas and that was
a communication is a huge thing I find
with friends of mine if we've done some
data viz coolness we will be swapping
URLs I mean that the our ability to
share is is enormously enhanced by the
fact that you can just stick it on a URL
and coconut with the browser and it all
works because the interpreter is stuck
inside the inside the browser
distribution goes hand in hand that's um
another thing obviously the web is
distribution so if you can't get your
data visit there easily if it's an
awkward threshold to to to get it there
then you're going to have problems it's
probably not going to happen as I said
the the humble URL is a token of
exchange so people are swapping your l's
that our data visualizations and they
are you can now you know you can roll
the cloud server and a few clicks I'll
give an example of that later in the
talk places like jsfiddle j has been
there's a new site called block builder
which means you can turn github gists
directly into d3 visualizations what is
happening is an incredibly rich
ecosystem is developing because of this
ease of transfer and skills are being
freely traded the standards are rising
all the time and it's happening within
the JavaScript ecosystem and the tool
sets are there in the language is there
to allow this to happen which is why I'm
a bit skeptical about attempts to
transpile from you know certain
languages into JavaScript they're there
I think they're going to kind of
ultimately fail because it's so
thickened at the moment so rich and the
barriers to entry are dropping all the
time I want to sort of discussed
JavaScript's development because there's
also a lot of prejudice you find in the
world of programming especially in
Python circles I think a lot of people's
experience of JavaScript maybe a few
years ago now and they have they have
developed a sense of it that that is no
longer the real picture I remember when
I was first doing a bit of web dev that
was forced upon me and I wanted to click
a button and I want this summer to
happen and i discovered this thing
called JavaScript and you have to do
this pretty horrible query selector all
out of
listen a thing and then you could get
something to happen when you click the
button you know you could have an alert
or a warning and then they appeared this
amazing thing called jQuery which just
made all these little horrible things
easier and Barry mine in those days all
the browsers were different they all had
their own embrace and extend standards
so jQuery fixed all that it meant you
could kind of just right for all the
browsers and that was lovely well i
think that the consequence of that is
that people associated javascript with a
whole other kind of rag bag of Dom hacks
and lift the utility libraries and just
just a general sense of just hack strung
together not a kind of language to
develop interesting and and and profound
code bases in so it was a toy it's ugly
clergy syntax low interpreter small code
bases difficult to scale not the sort of
thing you would use to be developing
cutting-edge data visualization for
example and lets you know face it
head-on because I think you should
appreciate the sheer ugliness that face
javascript is until very recently I've
no modules if you come from Python
that's that's astonishing you have
little script tags and you better put
them in the right order or you'll get
all sorts of interesting problems and
you would hack together your own sort of
pseudo modules to try and preserve your
name spaces or C Python is very big on
namespaces and that's a great thing
because namespace pollution is is
horrible javascript makes everything
global by default if you don't use of
r22 to define it then it becomes part of
the global namespace which is just
horrible these these things as these
things are becoming far these mistakes
are becoming far harder to make but that
is one thing this sort of thing could
SAP your will to live this is how you
get a default parameter okay
used to in JavaScript it's too horrible
for words but basically if a isn't
defined then you make a 42 you do that
enough times and yeah the language
starts the pool I'm just picking a few
at random the safe way to to to iterate
a list is just horrible I'm it's hacky
it's you can't just do four list in as
you could with Python because you'll
probably have artifacts or you'll
probably have array members you didn't
you didn't anticipate so that's the safe
way to do it but also just just wrong
but we're now in acma script 2016 the
new a prescrip which is coming to a
browser near you and it's almost there
and we have modules and we have default
parameters and no one I haven't used a
fully Luke for years I think arrays have
a for each method enables you to iterate
through them so a lot of the the crud
and the irritants are dropping away it
is becoming a much nicer language I can
testify to that and yes with imports
with modules you can get a bit more
ambitious without having to worry about
everything just falling apart I would
like this one it's now much much much
faster than Python JavaScript oice
orders of magnitude on many things like
embody simulations or spectral norms
there's been an arms race between the
big boys and you know Google Ledet with
v8 and javascript is now incredibly fast
for those of us working dataviz you are
getting to a point where you have kind
of you know CPU each to burn which is
which is lovely so you can have lots and
lots of things moving around
interactively and it increases the scope
of you know what you can possibly do so
just keeps getting better and better and
better it's great it's wonderful why
would you
use Python well the good news is
javascripts data processing step is
sucks completely it's awful pile that is
to do with javascript number is this
Java scripts and got this one catch all
numeric type called number which is
neither high nor hair and does very
funny things when it gets very big you
can even kind of had skipped integers
and stuff it's too too ridiculous so yes
basically to create a kind of a numpy
ecosystem in in javascript is going to
require not just syntactic sugar it's
going to require you know rethinking the
basis of the language so the might mean
so the power of pythons processing state
which i think is pretty much second to
none is the reason why when you're
playing with your data when you have
mark when you're cleaning it when you're
when you're refining it you want to be
using python which suggests this sort of
thing so i cover this particular kind of
tool chain or workflow in my book python
does all the scraping data collation
everything else does the cleaning it
does the the exploring it does the
delivery using a flask in this cage at
which point javascript takes over and
does the transformation the the wysiwyg
the pretties d3 is the library of choice
it's it's the biggest by far the biggest
and JavaScript data visualization lobby
and it's fantastically powerful and an
expressive what are your options I mean
I'd other alternative options to
embracing JavaScript on fighting the
bullet as I said down there the ipython
notebooks Jupiter etc are fantastic and
I think there are just amazing
contribution to the Python ecosystem
we've got plot Liam ba cable which can
convert matplotlib etc into something
you can stick on the web that will have
some degree of interactivity we've got
vega which is a visualization grammar
which you could potentially use to to
send that to browse where it'll usually
be converted into a visualization using
something like d3 they have their use
cases but i also think they have their
they have their limits limitations and
problems this is example of the Jupiter
kind of notebook thing it's I mean these
things are wonderful you can go to the
web you can launch on these you're going
to need a pipe interpret at the back end
but increasingly some of these widgets
the ones down here are becoming
JavaScript it's so in your browser you
can actually interact with them to a
limited degree the question is how much
that limited degree is so here's bouquet
and the work pocket website we can
should be able to something's happened
to bacha I can't click on it at the
moment but if I could click on the Bakke
website try it again then you would find
there we go so if we go to the Bakke
websites this is a Rennes attractor this
is JavaScript kid I can manipulate it
there you go in my browser window and I
have some basic little things here hands
and the rest to it now it's nice but
it's generic these are pretty much what
you're going to get you don't have a lot
of control over that it's it's nice it's
a nice demo but it's you're relying on
basically JavaScript experts to have
created this this API this this
environment for you and that's not
particularly empowering you're stepping
outside the JavaScript workflow when you
do this when you could do this to
transpire Python DJ s and the Java
workflows is very is a very kind of
powerful one it's got some amazing tools
like you know chrome web developer tools
and you're applying those to this sort
of transpire code is very difficult it's
hard to work with it's very hard to make
changes that propagate I've found that
write it in Direction is just I mean
debugging is a probably the larger part
of programming and when you have this
sort of indirection going for one
language to another you might massively
multiply the problems of debugging if
you want anything changed you're going
to rely on a JavaScript expert anyway so
you're not empowered you're essentially
relying on on experts to to do what you
want and they obviously won't do it in
the time scales you might require here's
one example that cropped up I just
thought I'd sort of make the point I had
to do a this particular chart recently
for a client and if we play it it's very
simple little line chart and you select
various demographic groups and this
gives a kind of a verification score for
them and this is what they kind of
specified they they asked for and
immediate problem is you've got these
you've got these clashing labels now
clashing labels is a perennial problem
for for database so the little things
that just take up all your time and so i
hacked a go on
so you go away and because you're
working with JavaScript and it's all
very anyway you have control over all of
the different elements you can just very
quickly create a little you know little
D 3 hack that make sure that the labels
are reasonably dispersed and that we
very hard to do with in a box plot Lee
or whatever situation and there's the
hacky function that just came together
but it got the job done and if you're
certainly few working with data viz in
you know for work for clients these
little controls this empowerment is
really important it's fundamental in
fact multiple elements figures are also
quite hard to do so I'm just yeah this
has got multiple elements and it
requires some understanding of HTML CSS
in order to to get these elements to
function together
now you know something's getting well
established when Microsoft start playing
around there this is what's cool sand
ants it's the sort of as a Microsoft
Project in-house that's all
browser-based and they've written their
own little kind of date of his tools
microsoft obviously have a potential
problem because they they'd only kill
the whole XL ecosystem any start stuff
starts going to the browser then maybe
people won't want to use their open
office their office software quite as
much but you can see the sort of thing
people are doing now they're getting
much more ambitious this was a
proprietary Microsoft solution but it's
it's pretty cool it's pretty impressive
example of data and boost on the browser
so what do you do if you want to get in
I'm say avoid all frameworks inoculate
yourself against js2 lightest there's so
many tools that you'll hear about you
don't need to worry about them many of
them are more trouble than it worth
initially just learn the basic a trim
elements investing some time in learning
SVG scalable vector graphics that would
really help don't worry about less or
SAS or compiled CSS just go vanilla
going on for everything start really
simple and don't use a tool unless it
justifies itself user tools you're
hitting a header hit your head against
the ceiling otherwise don't bother and
certainly don't touch frameworks until
you're comfortable with with vanilla
JavaScript which is a powerful language
so you go just an editor you need an
editor that can handle multiple
languages either I just setting up
syntax highlighting a browser I mean
chrome debugging tools are really very
impressive and a console for output we
have the concepts the single page app
which is you have a kind of entry point
an index.html this is a flask based
based one that's a self-contained
dataviz or job web data viz
folder and it's got the necessary CSS
j/s the data is the interesting thing
here first what you design your
visualization so you just sketch that
out in a piece of paper you write your
little index.html backbone so that sort
of like just tags placeholders for the
visual elements that you're going to
create using d3o javascript a little bit
of CSS to get it's a very robocop to get
the positions of those visual elements
and then you will you will have a entry
point for your visualization where the
data is fed in it looks something like
this you saw the cue your data and then
you'll build your amazing thing which I
won't get into accepts that's d3 and
it's a it's a big learning curve but I'm
going to talk about the data just
quickly now because it's everything I
mean essentially you just think of your
web data viz as a data feed and feeding
the data is fundamental and and then you
pick up the data on the client side and
you turn it into into wonderful stuff
how easy is it to deliver data these
days well let's consider this is an
array of JSON objects these are Nobel
Prize winners they have various fields
that you're interested in that you're
going to use to create your
visualizations and we want to be able to
deliver these and we don't want to
deliver them selectively as well you
have something like this you have a
website that would be your kind of basic
server site that will deliver the date
of his page the index dot HTML with all
the JavaScript and the rest of it and
that's going to be making a call out to
a
cloud-based let's say API data API which
will then send data back to be used this
is a very flexible system and how hard
is it to do that I mean few years ago
this would have been quite a challenge
so now here's this thing called Python
Eve which i think is a very nice little
library it's sort of MongoDB based flask
based library it has a configuration for
our settings pi where you set your [ __ ]
parameters Heroku which many of you will
probably have heard of is is going to
use to deploy this but it can also
obviously work locally so try to get the
environment variables that Herrick will
provide otherwise as defaults you set
various other things you have a little
schemer that tells you what data in the
MongoDB database you're going to release
and actual settings that is how you
create a and Eve or get set an EVE
server running as you can see it's few
lines if a haircut you'll have a little
prop file which will basically say start
up the eve server you'll have
requirements text file which will give
you which suggests over which mandates
eve nor point six one that will call in
all of the necessary Python libraries
into that virtual environment and here
is the entire process of creating a
cloud-based API Mongol API and you they
were getting it on the on that folder
with those four files you add the more
you commit initially you use Heroku
creates to create an app me I'm calling
Eve Heroku that works you add mongolab
as an add on a Heroku has a [ __ ] kind
of sand pit you can also use a real
[ __ ] you can use a scalable [ __ ]
DB which you pay for but this is the
sandpit works fine for small experiments
that'll goes in you do get push heroku
master bubba bubba ber and it spews out
this ad web address Eve Harry koo hara
co-opted a dumb so as you can see it's
that's just four or five command lines
you then have little script to fill it
up with your in this case Nobel data
that's just that you're just accessing a
[ __ ] database and then you can do curl
on your just to test it out test out
your API here I'm looking for all French
Nobel Prize winners and as you can see
it delivers them at which point you've
essentially got your data API you can
access that from your web browser your
client your web browser your JavaScript
and use it to create your data
visualizations so the conclusion is that
yes Python Java scripts are the most
powerful dataviz stack out there and I
think I've appreciated that more in the
last year if nothing else but they both
want to use their full potential and as
much as the kind of halfway house trance
piled solutions are are interesting and
definitely have they use cases I think
they're great for educational purposes
nearing else they're not going to cut it
in the modern world database because the
standards arising all the time and the
ambition is rising all the time and you
need to get down to the metal and that
means using the the tools available and
let's say the JavaScript development
environment is is amazing you can throw
together Gator api's few lines there's
so many ways to do it as you saw Heroku
is very easy AWS a digital ocean they're
all easy and then and you can a more
ties these skills that's what's nice you
learn to do them once and that's that
and so the idea i think is i push it in
the book a lot and
and I think that's quite fundamental is
you can really limit the amount of web
dev or what you probably used to
associate with with with web there you
can really reduce that to it to a bare
minimum just creating as kind of a
skeleton that you'll then flesh out
programmatically and then just turn all
your energies to creating interesting
engaging interactive visualizations with
any luck and that's that's it that's a
weird great great talk really left with
necklace and so you're talking a lot
about so the visualizing data I'm
thinking so the last have made your app
I build it was sort of more had a
backhanded in Scala for java based and
then let you have scripted
I you think sort of suggesting that you
can almost completely do away with that
ultra largest scale projects or a gorg
how you sort of thinking about more
application web applications most a
visualization um in terms of this that's
area so I the question is I think I
understand you Riley the degree to which
I guess javascript is going to call a
nice the full stack yeah then I guess I
guess also Python at the back end I mean
because it is as you say to light the
libraries are so powerful for the data
analysis of the data is there do you
need to put in Scala or another compiled
language to serve the actual application
um yeah I mean I guess I see is a
process of refinement so you get your
raw data wherever it comes wrong you
might be clean that you refine it and
yet to a point where I mean I guess you
want the most refined data possible to
be delivered to the browser because
javascript is not very good at doing
very much it's awkward to use JavaScript
or to do anything with it at that point
so I see I mean I do see is the Python
or scholar or anything else their job is
to essentially distill the data is to is
to deliver a faux concentrated data form
in a way that is easy to use and
generally look at the rule of thumb is
you know you want your date the liver
day to be as close as possible to the
stuck you'll be sent to the three
whatever lowest number of manipulations
but you certainly do need other
languages in the backend JavaScript's
data processing is not not there
probably will never be
can you and you get something else
pretty quick question is how high is the
barrier to entry I think that barrier to
entry is an awful lot lower than most
people appreciate as long as you don't
listen to any JavaScript fanboys because
they all tell you unique gulp and grunts
and watch files and all the rest of it
and you don't you just need an editor
there is a I think there's a sound
obviously looking at the history
JavaScript there is insecurity there
because other people are used to being
told they're plain language and I think
they've tried to fill that gap with lots
and lots of tools and pipelines and pipe
flows and all this stuff and and they've
created this complex mess it has its
place probably if you're working with
big teens but I would say the barracks
are introducing is incredibly low in
fact it's the lowest barrier to entry of
any language I know because you can go
to jsfiddle J spin play around you can
go to block builder for d3 there's
eleven thousand examples that are all
active they're active there's eleven
thousand examples there they have the
code they have the data you can change
the code change the data interactively
that's why I think JavaScript was just
elected the teaching language of what
the American teachers association I
think is just overtaken pison so yeah
it's low I'm so as long as you ignore
certain people so that you are
I saying about roman 11 use any of the
tolling think that the definition
Halloweeny also was mentioning the newer
versions of Shalott are much nicer for
years old and the thing is that most of
them are not really well support so you
start needing some conversion tools how
do you handle those differences think
I'm support with ESC yeah it's the
question is all these funky new
JavaScript additions aren't quite there
yet they they're very close I mean this
space is happening within within the i
would say six months or a year it's not
less than that a lot of them can already
already be used people use various
things like fable i think is one and i
personally because I'm I haven't been
using than much because I I've got my
old old ways of doing it so I haven't
had to run into that problem too much
but I know told who's sitting next year
what would you use the component he is
they both we only do better and you find
that was exhausting high stools that
kind of
I get any person talking to people in
community that it works very well and
there are some debugging issues but
generally speaking people are getting
used to just converting their expert 6
into browser compliant code without a
bunch of trouble